Hey everybody! Send a raven. They've started announcing who the season 8 cast members
they're going to be bringing on our. So this will be a breakdown of that.
Just careful for spoilers for everything through season 7. Just because we'll have to talk about a little bit of golden company stuff.
I think one of the roles that they're casting is for that storyline.
Possibly two, but there are seven new cast members
they've announced. Per the Watchers on the wall people, they were able to get their hands on the first casting notices.
So these aren't big secrets or anything like that,
but it's always a surprise that they are able to bring in so many new people each season. And that doesn't include the
multitudes of red shirts that they have for big crowd shots. Like when they have Grey Worm standing here at the end of season 7.
There's obviously a whole bunch of Dothraki that ride in, you have the Unsullied,
but there are a lot of background actors that don't have names that they just bring on for that day.
There is a new round of the giveaway for that new book that George R. R.
Martin released about Aegon's sons. All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber and leave a comment on this video.
So all of these seven
characters is part of this new season 8 cast are actually people that will have on-screen roles and will possibly
interact with the main characters. A really good comparison would be Alys Karstark
during the beginning of season 7. Like we didn't really see her after those first couple of episodes
but she did have important scenes. So as you can imagine from that intro, most of these are northern characters.
There are a couple that will be shooting in Spain, so that means King's Landing. So that's where we get to Golden Company stuff
but I'll start with the Winterfell people. So first up is a northern farmer somewhere in his mid-20s mid-30s.
He's supposed to be a straightforward honest man of simple taste who works with the land.
It is part of these casting notices. It does say when they're filming but for the most part
it's between November and December. So it's all
relatively close to the same period. But I'll go through all the names first then I'll talk about
what they actually might be doing with these characters. The next one is just called sassy and attractive girl.
Which I think sounds hilarious. Totally sounds like a northern person, maybe somebody from Bear Island.
But she's meant to be a little bit younger, like late teens early 20s. The character is said to be sexy and confident
Northern girl playing a good memorable one scene part in one episode playing opposite leading cast.
So then there's a northern century, also about the same age, a little bit younger.
They're looking for a northern actor with great timing to play a small part
opposite the leading cast. So that sounds like the gate guards that Arya ran into. So sometimes
they cast people just to stand there and nod and say lines. Sometimes they actually have to have like really awesome
performances. So that's why they're looking for extra good actors even though some of these roles are relatively minor. Moving south,
they're looking for a sailor character, which pretty much reads Ironborn, a little bit older. Somewhere below the age of fifty.
He's supposed to be rough-and-ready
seafaring type with a weathered face and strong presence. Then they're looking for a guard who's supposed to be in his 20s.
Just physically fit, able to handle himself in a fight. Just has to look kind of like a badass. They don't really specify
what his skin color is supposed to be or what ethnicity so it's hard to place him. He could show up
anywhere. He could be up at Winterfell, or it could be south at King's Landing, but then they get a little bit more specific.
There's just somebody listed as guard number two, who's supposed to be a little bit older, in his 30s. They're looking for someone
that's tall, athletic, with a military feel. Supposed to be professional clear-thinking guard who is dependable.
He's going to be in multiple scenes. It will shoot in Spain and he'll be with the leading cast.
So just to explain
what they're doing with each of those characters. Like the character that shows up in Spain, that last guard that I mentioned, that's
probably in King's Landing.
That's where they shoot most of their King's Landing scenes. They shoot in Ireland for all their Winterfell scenes, with a few exceptions. Sometimes
they'll go up to Iceland for like the really big scenes north of the Wall.
But they've changed that a little bit.
Remember they built out that giant quarry as the lake set for episode 6. That was meant to double for a lot of their Iceland
scenes when they would go north of the Wall.
But like the reason I included that
Winterfell shot is because that's where they're going. So most of like all this big stuff at the beginning of the season will take place
in and around Belfast.
But just going down the list. The northern farmer, the sassy attractive girl, are just meant to sort of build out give more character to
the people of the north to make it feel more real. You've really only spent time at Winterfell.
But like remember back during season 6, we did get a bit of a tour of the north.
So it did humanize it a little bit,
but not in the way that you would want. Because other than the Little Bear, we really only met Lord Glover, and he was really
unsympathetic to their cause.
So they actually really want to make you care about it. Like if Lord Glover were torn to shreds
you probably wouldn't shed any tears.
But then you have characters like Ros, who you get to know during season 1 and even though she's a
relatively salacious character, they just want to help put a face on the northern people that Jon Snow is so
desperate to protect.
So like the northern farmer character is meant to be more salt of the land. Like I'm just trying to make my way in the
world. The sassy attractive girl sounds like more of a comedy scene so maybe something with Tyrion.
Maybe he tries to hit on somebody or something with Jamie.
Just some awkward comedy where she isn't having any of their bullshit.
But like I said the northern century just sounds like it's meant to be a really memorable character like the Arya gate guards.
Maybe not quite so
comedic. Like that was actually a pretty brilliant scene the way they played it. Even though you probably don't remember their names.
You just remember the really funny gate guards. The sailor
character is very obviously going to be Ironborn.
Remember Euron is going to get the Golden Company so because they're filming with that character a little bit later in December,
it sounds like that will actually be a Golden Company scene with them either on one of the ships or them arriving at King's Landing.
We already talked about that second guard, even though
they only specify the
second guard is supposed to be in Spain. The first guard might be hand-in-hand with that like you have a younger character with a slightly
older guard character.
So they're probably
something tied to Cersei. And like I've said before, they start shooting in the middle of October.
And most of these new characters don't start shooting till the middle of November.
So just turning the timeline, it sounds like that first month of shooting that they have will be mostly main characters doing a lot of
the reunion moments at Winterfell. Like Jon Snow, Daenerys arriving. Maybe Gendry arrives. Jaime
probably arrives. Bronn shouldn't be too far behind him. You have the Hound so you get through all the really cool stuff
first and then you start exploring the stuff that's going in and around Winterfell.
Which is where you get the
background characters. There isn't much of an indication about what's going to be happening with Cersei in the first couple of episodes.
Because it sounds like it's gonna
take a little while for the Golden Company to arrive.
But they could be filming a lot of that separately because it's meant to be such a big thing.
It'll require some special effects especially for all those ship-based scenes with Euron. For the most part
it sounds like she's going to be spending most of her time at least early on in that map room.
Just talking about the things that she's done so far since the end of last season. Assuming
there's a bit of a time gap.
Just trying to win over the rest of the southern lords that are on the fence that aren't sure whether or not they want to
support Jon Snow and Daenerys because of everything that's happened.
Think of it as another version of this scene here where she was trying to paint Daenerys as this really terrible
conqueror only she adds White Walkers into that pile.
"-but house Tyrell is in open rebellion against the crown."
"With their help, the Mad King's daughter has ferried an army of savages to our shores."
"mindless Unsullied soldiers who will destroy your castles and your holdfasts."
"Dothraki heathens who will burn your villages to the ground."
But let me know in the comments, which other new characters
do you want them to include
during season 8? Now these aren't the only characters that they're casting these are just people that will be shooting before the end of the
Year. Remember they're gonna be shooting all the way up to the summer of next year.
So there's all of next year for more characters like this. So if we do get any more casting updates
I'll do new videos. But my next Game of Thrones video will be a breakdown of that new Aegon Targaryen story.
It's about his children really, so I'll try to get that out in the next couple of days.
But congratulations to - youonlyliveonce -
you're the latest giveaway winner. You win a copy of that new book.
Please private message me on the back end of my channel so I can get your contact details.
You can click here for more Rhaegar and Lyanna
And you can click here to rewatch Maisie Williams new Marvel movie that she's in. She actually turns into a wolf. The wolf
turns into a wolf in the Marvel Universe. Thank you so much for watching. Everybody stay awesome. I'll see you guys tonight.